all right let's get into this week's
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say please don't abuse the email
unfortunately the more the reason i keep
saying this is we now have
over a hundred different people that are
emailing us so regularly almost using
our email address like a blog free free
association
of whatever's going through their minds
we have over 100 people whose emails are
automatically filtered into a folder
that we never look at unless law
enforcement says please forward us your
communications with these people which
sometimes happens but please don't abuse
it okay don't let's let's uh keep it
let's keep it respectful all right let's
jump right into it here
um here's someone who sounds reasonable
why aren't you talking about the biden
crime family dragging us into war the
berezma deal with hunter biden is going
to have the usa in war with russia
and because biden colluded with russia
gave them the pipeline we have no
bargaining and we're over a barrel this
will not be a just war but an evil war
of course you won't because you're
nothing but a communist propagandist a
liar lying your damn ass off
um
brutal attack brutal attack on the
english language here
i actually think
that um
it's legally a requirement that if you
write hate mail you have to use the
wrong your versus your like you
apostrophe it's it seems to be a legal
requirement from what i'm getting if we
end up in a conflict with russia
it will not be the united states alone
and it will not be because of hunter
biden
i don't know that there's that much else
to say here
and so i won't say anything else
next message only commie idiots like you
think democrats are actually good
in one line you can pack such
disinformation
and this one is funny because i'm
neither a communist
nora democrat
and as those who have been following the
show for some time know
i get criticized by the actual
socialists because i'm not a socialist
and then the right says i am a socialist
or in this case a communist in terms of
democrats are good
i think
i'm one of the most
consistently
indifferent to the democratic party
i'm not as actively hostile to it as
others are
but i don't care at all about the
democratic party i've never been a
democrat i see the democratic party as
having as its number one goal
self-preservation they want to stay in
power
and i really couldn't care less about
the democratic party as far as democrats
are good if you're talking about how i
vote i look at each race
i look at the candidates and i pick the
one that i think would do the least
damage and the most good it's it's
it's almost boring
but no not a communist not a democrat
either michael wrote in about religious
exemptions michael says hey david i just
watched your segment about the
serviceman who was asking for the
religious exemption for the vaccine he
said something about the pedigree of
technology or something and then ended
with convicted in the spirit
then you rightly pointed out all the
other vaccines that service members are
required to get and asked where in the
bible or other religious texts does it
say
one list is fine but the covid vaccine
is bad
mike writes the only thing he said that
he could argue to those who speak his
language going back to amanda montel's
cult language concepts is convicted in
the spirit
as a recent convert away from
christianity i still recognize the coded
language of the group this means in
short god is telling him not to get the
vaccine and that is his justification
for religious exemption not any text any
rational person wouldn't be able to
follow his logic but most in christendom
would that's very interesting so it's
sort of like a get out of jail free card
um if you say well my reli i'm against
it for religious reasons and then
someone like me shows up and i
understand i got a very nice email from
a lawyer who said
legally it's problematic to say show us
where your religion says that i get it
but someone like me shows up in a
conversation and i go oh
where does your religion say that it
seems that this i'm convicted by the
spirit not to get the vaccine
is sort of like a
get out of jail free catch-all where you
can drop that in and it could basically
just be god told me
god told me not to get it and of course
that puts us in the realm of
indefeasible well i don't know whether
whatever this person thinks god told
them
we can't really prove or disprove one
way or the other
many of you writing in about the recent
word salads
from jordan peterson
and one such person was kim
kim wrote in and said hey david
regarding jordan peterson's incoherent
biblical rant i believe it was his
attempt to explain that the bible as we
know it today
is a collection of books for example the
book of matthew is a book
that's included in the bible
i think you were right when you said
that his word salad tricks people into
thinking he's smarter than they are
peterson says enough logical
well-thought-out comments to bait his
audience this interview is obviously not
well thought out and referring to clips
of him from years ago but once he hooks
his listeners he leads them down the
in-cell pipeline that creates school
shooters that's very very aggressive and
i suspect
not completely without merit
but um yeah the the
the tough thing about jordan peterson
is he always did the word salads and
they were always very borderline in
terms of being
sort of interesting
and being wacky disjointed delusions
and i think it's it's only gotten like
five percent worse but it was so
borderline to begin with that now it's
very clearly over the line that that's
sort of my sense of it um and we we've
got some more jordan peterson stuff
uh coming up to talk about
rodney wrote in
about me
leaving the country
and
again
sort of a misunderstanding rodney wrote
this is why sometimes i'm like i
shouldn't even talk about certain things
because it will be so misunderstood
rodney said david my wife and i are
proud to be members who joined without
accepting a discount so we could further
your broadcast experience thank you
rodney i appreciate that we enjoy your
program very much and rarely miss a show
you've talked about how it's necessary
to take these crazy right wingers such
as matt gates and newt gingrich
seriously there are probably a few who
do not but i think most of your
listeners recognize the seriousness of
what these people are saying and what
they will do if they get the opportunity
what would you have us do now that you
know we are taking them seriously we
would not vote for them ever what else
can we do we are ready
so if things become bad in this country
you're gonna leave or perhaps i should
say if things get worse
most of us do not have the means to just
leave even if we wanted to do so it's a
little disheartening to realize that is
your intention it's like that old
expression when the going gets tough the
tough get going out of the country it's
kind of like abandoning your teammates
in my view until then keep up the good
work
let me say
again
i have no plan to leave the country i
have no plan to leave the country i i
would love to spend more time
in the place i was born argentina
and maybe after the pandemic it'll be a
possibility
but i've no plan to leave my uh
immediate family is in the united states
my work is in the united states
most everybody i know is in the united
states i have no plan to leave the
question was if it got so bad you felt
you had to leave where would you go and
i listed the places
that's all
i'm not abandoning everybody
i have no plan to leave and i shouldn't
even have have brought it up
uh okay next email mike says just admit
that you're a democrat already
you claiming that you're not a democrat
is the equivalent of tim poole claiming
he isn't a republican
i don't know anything about tim poole's
party registration
i i just don't so i can't talk about tim
poole
when i claim i'm not a democrat i'm just
telling you the truth
i've never been a democrat
i don't care about the democratic party
as an institution
i believe as i said
ten minutes ago in this segment
uh that the democratic party's main goal
is its own self-preservation
not the good of the average person
so i would be lying if i said i was a
democrat now
mostly
in the modern era
in partisan elections i'm opting to vote
for the democrat but i don't do anything
with the democratic party i don't donate
to it i don't fundraise i don't care
about it so when i say i'm not a
democrat i'm just telling you the truth
all right here's the last one and this
one is
as crazy as anything i have ever
received
jj wrote to me
did you know biden made sure the
hospitals stay bankrupted by making it
so the water runs on electricity
that makes it so water for hospitals no
longer free
the same with the paper towel dispensers
almost everything got hooked up to
electricity
there are zero hospitals in america i
didn't know that
the doctor no longer check the suction
cup part of the vagina
so females might die from a tampon being
stuck
in their bodies you know i have to say
the other day i wrote i drove by some
places where there used to be hospitals
all i saw was suction cups the hospitals
are gone so maybe jj is on to something
no in all seriousness
um
this is this is scary this is scary
wacky i don't know what jj is talking
about we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joinpackman.com
you'll get instant access and remember
you can send me your thoughts that may
be featured in the mailbag
info
davidpakman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show or otherwise monday